Robert dubois he's in prison for putting superman
in the icu with the kryptonite bullet i'm
not joining your suicide squad we'll see my
court date is coming up and miss waller and
maybe you could help me out you're stretching
in my door everyone stand down stand down
i wouldn't take such extreme measures this
mission went more important than you could
possibly imagine are you in or out hey guys
sorry i'm late i had to go number two good
to know is this thing a dog a dog what kind
of dog do you think it is mate i'm gonna go
with afghan hound oh my god is it a werewolf
yo they stopped me next to a widow yo let
me out yeah he's not a werewolf okay he's
a weasel he's harmless i mean he's not harmless
he's killed 27 children but you know your
mission is to destroy every trace of something
known only as project starfish any questions
starfish is a slang term for a butthole think
there's any connection
no no
all right let's get it
this is suicide well that's kind of our thing
i'm a superhero that's my dad
I'm gonna get you out of here alive. I'm going to get you
out of here alive
ratatouille what do you got
bird
Nanaue
stay off the com
Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my brand new suicide squad trailer i bet you
didn't think that you were going to wake up
listening to john cena talking about buttholes
and starfish there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs here i'll explain where this fits in
the dc continuity there's a bunch of stuff
going on they have big plans for some of these
characters too that are going to continue
on to the peacemaker tv series the spin-off
series they're doing for john cena's peacemaker
character that we're actually going to get
episodes for in january next year so if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos i will also be doing full
episode videos for that peacemaker hbo tv
series when they do release it but i just
love how they're trying to give john cena
the most wtf lines possible in all these trailers
like in the last trailer it was about sucking
all the d on the beach now he's going on being
super serious about buttholes like he's taking
this dead serious no hint of irony or joking
in his voice and i love the way idris elba's
head almost swivels around on his body just
to give him that look like dude seriously
seriously the other really funny thing here
too big coincidence i know we're in the middle
of marvel's loki series on disney plus in
the mcu obviously no real connection there
because it's the mcu but this base where most
of the action takes place where they're experimenting
on starro where he goes crazy is actually
supposed to be this former nazi base but it's
called yodenheim named after the realm of
the frost giants where loki comes from james
gunn obviously big marvel director he didn't
do that on purpose the whole idea is that
most of the movie takes place in courthole
maltese which is this big location from the
batman comics that they've used in the movies
and a lot of the tv shows it's meant to be
this big port of call for dc villains big
warlords like this lawless place in the world
where you can go and do really shady stuff
so no big surprise that it would have ties
to the nazis like nazis after world war ii
went to hayden argentina a lot of nazis went
to do really shady stuff here a long time
ago around world war ii and since then it's
just been taken over by a bunch of local warlords
but they use most of this trailer to hype
up idris elba's bloodsport character robert
dufois who's serving his sentence in belrev
prison for shooting superman with a kryptonite
bullet henry cavill's superman just confirming
that this does have ties to the dceu especially
because of margot robbie's version of harley
quinn but as amanda waller says he put superman
in the icu and even though they don't explain
much about their history together like his
history was superman in the comics his character
was hired by lex luthor to assassinate superman
so i think that's also kind of the idea here
like he was hired by lex luthor for an ungodly
sum of money to try and kill superman but
the events of this movie are supposed to take
place after the events of the justice league
snyder cut so obviously not getting into the
whole nightmare scene flash forward the big
time travel plot during the snyder cut sequels
but the idea is that during that movie with
a lot of time travel from the flash they would
have eventually defeated darkseid and things
would have slowly gone back to normal around
the world all the justice league members at
a certain point would have gone on to their
regular lives day to day just saving people
like they normally would so within a couple
years of that happening lex luthor hires bloodsport
to assassinate superman and he's almost successful
the big twist though that he doesn't want
to have anything to do with amanda waller's
task force x he doesn't seem surprised by
the notion though like he knows all about
it like yeah yeah i got it go screw yourself
i don't want anything to do with your crappy
team attention to detail as well when he's
scrubbing the floor there inside bellerov
prison it looks like he's scraping off a piece
of human skin but then they set the whole
arc with his daughter to make you sympathize
with him a little bit so that he doesn't seem
like such a bad person amanda waller makes
it seem like his daughter has this big court
case like she might go to prison too for a
long time and the only way that it's going
to go well for her that she's going to win
her court case is if bloodsport joins the
team the whole idea though with amanda waller
is that she's supposed to feel like one of
the main villains even though technically
she's not the actual main villain like she's
supposed to feel as bad as some of the main
villains the idea with suicide squad movies
is there always is some kind of main antagonist
but because it's a movie about villains traditionally
they want to make them feel more like anti-heroes
in more of shades of gray so no one's really
good no one's really bad like at some point
you'll probably sympathize with starro i think
the idea here the way they set it up is that
they found him or they captured him when he
was really small really young and they've
been experimenting on him this whole time
and he just naturally grown to this huge size
so even though starro is this huge dc villain
like he's the og justice league villain if
you've read that original justice league story
their first big team up starro was the first
villain that they fought together so normally
you think of him as this really bad force
in the universe but i think the idea is that
during the movie you sympathize with him a
little bit because the government or this
faction of the military has been experimenting
on him this whole time i love the way amanda
waller sets up the plan though operation starfish
has gone completely off the rails based on
staro's powers it sounds like the government
or the military faction responsible for this
whole experiment was trying to use starro
as a means of creating a more controllable
army like more effective soldiers and because
it seems like peter capaldi's version of the
thinker was here long before the suicide squad
rolls up it sounds like they're trying to
use him as part of this big experiment because
his main power is mind control they've done
versions of the thinker before but not quite
this comic book accurate looking like he looks
very close to comic book thinker and i believe
he's supposed to be the clifford devoe version
but he looks very much like the new 52 design
of the thinker so he's not really a member
of the suicide squad so to speak but he's
down there and they use him as part of their
plan like they have that whole big funny sequence
in the last trailer like if you do anything
wrong we will kill you on the spot but like
i said it sounds like based on the way starro
just bursts out of this giant yodenheim nazi
base that they had been keeping him locked
up underground and had some way of preventing
superman and other heroes around the world
other superheroes from detecting that he was
there because you think that superman would
try to do something if he found out about
a giant starfish from space that was mind
controlling people i think the idea though
is that they probably captured starro before
superman came into his powers or even maybe
before he crashed to planet earth james gunn
is a huge comic book nerd so usually they
build in explainers like that during the movie
there'll be some funny way of explaining how
other superheroes like the justice society
dr fate did not find out about starro they've
also finished a lot more of the visual effects
on this too i love the effect that they use
for starro with his main ability spawning
thousands of smaller starfish using them to
mind control everybody in these big crowd
shots here like you have to imagine that there's
this giant army outside all being mind controlled
by starro they also explain some of his lesser
abilities here too like he has these small
tendrils that come out of his arms that he
uses to grab king shark and throw him into
a building explaining how starro can actually
physically grab things and even though they
give some of the crazier lines to john cena's
peacemaker character who's like the douchebag
version of captain america like imagine the
douchiest version of captain america you could
think of they do not shy away from any wcf
harley quinn jokes like sorry guys sorry i'm
late i just had to pull a number two just
had to drop a deuce but ready to go now and
i love the dynamic between some of these team
members here too obviously we have a lot of
characters returning from the first suicide
squad movie so they'll also explain the timeline
and what was going on with that too like the
idea that this is just the next version of
the suicide squad team the next roster in
a long line of different teams that she's
put together i think the idea was that will
smith had some sort of schedule conflict or
didn't want to come back for this movie and
that's why they got idris elba like they were
originally thinking about recasting his version
of deadshot but then decided just to make
idris elba a completely different character
so there are some characters from that original
team that are still alive that just didn't
come back for this version of the team i cannot
wait for james gunn to try and redeem captain
boomerang he wasn't that great during the
first suicide squad movie so there's nowhere
to go for that character but up the way that
james gunn also explained it too talking more
about carryover from the first film is that
there is no joker in this version of the movie
harley queen is showing up here after the
events of the birds of prey movie she gets
arrested for some other crime then gets thrown
back in bellerop prison she didn't kill the
joker during that film so jared leto's joker
is still alive in the dc eu and obviously
we just saw him during the justice league
snyder gun and he survived to that flash forward
nightmare scene there'll probably be some
brief references to him during this film just
to explain the timeline the continuity but
for the most part he's not really a character
during the film the only other really big
characters that i know of that are in the
trailer that aren't actually members of the
core team are alice braga's character she's
named soul soria she's supposed to be the
leader of the local resistance on corto matis
fighting against this dictator called sylvia
luna played juan diego boda she seems like
she just winds up helping them out during
their mission but some of these characters
that you see during the trailer will come
back for the john cena peacemaker tv series
so i don't know if that means that they're
going to be doing a lot of bell rev stuff
during that it sounds like they'd have to
because for instance jen holland's character
here who's like amanda waller's assistant
she's a character on the peacemaker tv series
so her character's coming back for that so
i'm assuming that if she works at bell rev
that they're also doing bell rep during that
the way james gunn has talked about it he
hasn't completely explained the timeline of
the peacemaker series like if it all takes
place after the events of the suicide squad
film i think he just doesn't want to give
it away because he doesn't want to tell you
whether or not john cena survives but i think
the idea is that he does survive the events
of the film and some of the peacemaker series
will take place after but they'll also use
it to tell his origin story and how he became
that character so there'll be flashbacks on
it too they haven't really said much about
any other huge cameo scenes from the other
justice league actors but like i said obviously
this is connected to the dc eu because of
marco robbie's harley quinn and the other
characters from the first suicide squad movie
there's been a lot happening with the dc movies
lately they're in the middle of filming the
flash movie right now we actually finally
got our first look at supergirl so this is
the new version supergirl it's a very injustice
looking version of the costume but it's based
on henry cavill's superman costume the designs
and we finally got to see michael keaton's
batman in the flesh walking around interacting
with the other characters we actually got
our first look at the new shazam costumes
as well this is the entire shazamly and now
mary marvel the actress who place her is old
enough that she's playing both versions of
the character the powered up and the non-powered
up version but if you have any big questions
about what's going on with the suicide squad
or the continuity with the other justice league
movies and characters just let me know in
the comments below i will do more dc videos
as we get more footage from all the movies
we'll probably get a new trailer for the batman
movie with robert pattinson a little bit later
this year too my full loki episode 3 video
will post next while you wait for everything
click here for my full loki episode 2 video
and click here to learn how loki just set
up the events of spider-man no way home in
doctor strange 2.
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys tonight!